(distant clapping)
(jingling sound)
(rustling noises)
(dog barking)
And today,
I feel like my entire life just opened up.
I basically am in wizard of Oz.
I'm Dorothy.
I left the black and white,
and I just walked into technicolor.
(Jill laughing)
Listen to me about this.
This is a bouquet.
This is the dried flowers.
It's a company called Urban Stems.
Now you guys,
do you ever wanna send people flowers,
around the country and you're freaking out,
about like,
a good local florist,
Yeah.
or is it going to come out okay?
Like this is very stressful to me.
I understand.
Yeah all the time.
This company goes all over the country
and you can do beautiful fresh flowers,
dried flowers.
You can do little plants and cactuses and succulents.
This is,
so sheek.
It's so of this world,
and time and life,
and you can totally clock it.
And it's so elevated and well done.
And yet it's accessible,
and I've been waiting for something like this my whole life.
I love this so you can send dried flowers,
like this?
Yeah and you can pick
That's beautiful.
your container.
Really?
Yeah and it's curated by different,
they have different collabs with people who've designed,
They did one with Vogue,
With Vogue,
with like a cool octagonal black one,
there it's,
it's very sheek.
It's very sheek.
And for the first time in my life,
Urban Stems has,
like I said,
changed my life to Technicolor.
So,
I love these so much.
And we have a very special,
thing to tell you which is,
we're gonna send them to our very special Drew gooders.
That are on the show.
Which is people that we shine a light on,
who are just making the world a better place,
and being the human example to us all.
So drew getters are getting this care,
of Urban Stem across the entire country.
So thank you to Urban Stem.
And where have you been all my life?
(Rosy laughing)
I just wanna thank Jill and Rosy for hanging out today.
This really was a Valentine's day treat.
Happy Valentine's to you.
We love you.
(audience clapping)
Happy Valentine's day.
Love you guys what are you doing for Valentine's day?
We're going to Vermont.
(Clapping fades)
You are?
Yeah.
It's winter wonderland right now.
It really is Rosy?
I'll be out celebrating Valentine's day.
You know,
I'm going out.
It's a happy time for me.
I'll be alone.
Yeah,
I was just gonna ask.
(Rosy laughs)
I'll be alone.
Eating carbohydrates and regretting it.
But I don't care because these are my life choices,
and I own them.
(Rosy laughing)
But thank you so much for watching.
(laughter continues)
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
And we hope,
that we're lucky enough to see you again tomorrow.
We'll be,
I'll be your Valentine.
(clapping continues)
Oh Drew.
(bright upbeat music)
(bright upbeat music fades)